in our series medical price roulette we
reveal how Americans pay wildly
different prices for the same medical
procedures our series is a collaboration
with clear health costs today the last
day of breast cancer awareness month we
are looking at the cost of mammograms
and follow-up tests more than 30 million
women will get a mammogram this year but
many tell us that while they thought
subsequent tests rather were free and
preventive they ended up with big big
bills our consumer investigative
correspondent that's Anna Warner is here
and a nobody likes sticker shock so why
is this happening right gale the
Affordable Care Act provided for free
mammograms every one to two years for
women aged 40 and over but many women
are called back for a second look and
some told us they wound up with
unexpected bills for hundreds of dollars
in Topeka Kansas
Sonya Johnson says she went from a
regular mammogram then got a call
doctors saw something unusual in the
images I kind of panic that's like oh my
gosh you saw what Johnson says she has a
common condition dense breast tissue so
the doctors did a follow-up tests
ultrasounds on both breasts the result
nothing to worry about health-wise but
financially I got this huge bill the
bill said she owed 646 dollars for those
ultrasounds I didn't even think that I
was gonna get charged because is is
preventative and you know my first
appointment didn't cost me anything not
even a co-payment so I'm thinking you
know they called me you know I wasn't
expecting a bill at all the Affordable
Care Act requires many insurance plans
to cover mammograms as a preventive
benefit every one to two years for women
age 40 or older but about 40% of those
women have dense breasts and often need
a secondary test their insurance won't
pay for
I think it's hidden and I think it's it
needs to be more open and transparent
that I need to know you know we're gonna
have a two-part if we see something
we're gonna have to have you come back
and that will cost you Johnson isn't
alone with her 646 dollar bill a woman
in Marilyn
told us she wound up paying $350 for
additional tests another in California
told us she was charged 912 dollars for
an additional test during her routine
screening some women are charged for
these tests without knowing that it's
not covered by their insurer Pat help
and Murphy heads the Pennsylvania Breast
Cancer Coalition but women want to know
whether that anomaly in their breast is
breast cancer or not so they say okay
I'll take the additional screening test
and then they get these enormous bills
and they can't pay them that's
unreasonable
and I think unconscionable and we want
to change that the Coalition says in
dense breasts mammograms miss more than
50 percent of cancers present
legislation proposed in Pennsylvania
would require insurers to cover the
additional screenings including
ultrasounds and MRIs for women with
dense breasts and others at increased
risk for breast cancer if this is my
preventative care and it's supposed to
be part of my insurance no I should not
be charged for it the Coalition says
cancer is four to six times more likely
in women with extremely dense breasts
and not covering follow-up tests will
cost lives the organization does offer
financial assistance to women in
Pennsylvania there are some similar
groups nationwide but without
legislation ensures may not have to
cover these tests so if you'd like to
share the prices you've paid for
mammograms and tests or any other
medical procedures with us go to CBS
news.com slash health costs or email at
health costs at CBS news.com raising
some really important issues yeah a
great series medical price roulette I
would you know what I wish and I wish
they would come up with another way to
do the mammogram let those young young
scientists we had on yesterday wish they
could come with they'll be there
honestly if men had to have their penis
squished the way that women do with
their breasts like a pancake they'd come
up with another they come up with
another way to do it that's the truth
men do face their own trials in tribute
thanks for that thought you're welcome